sono state rino ha un occhio talk show
che quando arrivava il momento di aprire
e lancio sbagliato su da stefano
stochino tanto ne sono tornato ciao
ragazzi bentornati una nuova puntata di
vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è ex ex per un tema così importante
ho pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios di casa mia l'unica persona che
ha diciamo un passato più burrascoso del
mio è molto più infelice rispetto al mio
una persona che conosco bene che è la
mia cuginetta preferita purtroppo lei
non poteva venire e quindi optato per la
linea
ciao a tutti ciao norante perfetta
pubblicamente fatto anche se però amo
definirmi più un auguro delle relazioni
familiari si dice tanto la linea e mia
cugina
no in realtà io sono una che papa va qua
sotto e poi immaginate fare mia cugina
ho pensato che fosse la persona migliore
per trattare un tema così spinoso io ho
il terrore di quello che potrebbe facile
colorante sì io sono qui per prendere i
vostri consigli fondamentali ragazzo
faceva la rotta vino questo gingillo
davanti ma anche in senso che prima
quando mi dicono le cose ed elicottero
poi perché non è un aeroplano ma è un
elicottero che sua madre me lo immagino
tipo beyoncé con l'aria davanti
il concerto ospite oggi volevo
raccontarti di quella volta in cui
conosciuto questo ragazzo
siamo usciti una sera ea fine serata mi
fa io devo chiederti una cosa sembra
molto preoccupato che tranquillizzandolo
il migliore cioè quelle cose che non
vanno
devo dirti che mi piacciono il calcio
puoi tirarmene 1 prima di andare a casa
no non l'ho mai più rivisto ciao ciao
cara posso darti tornato in carcere
marola lungi da me voler giudicare le
attitudini e le opzioni sessuali di
ciascuno di noi però diciamo che proprio
appena conosciuta forse era un po too
much una persona avevo conosciuto che
voleva prendere addio
oddio non lo so se sono pronto
arrotolata i peli del pube distaccava
faceva la pallina e di appoggiata sulla
sponda del letto oppure sul comodino e
io provavo tutti questi queste palline
di di pelo in giro ma gli andava pure un
nome che gira fatto mi tirate hai
sbagliato via vt canosa bello essere si
è fatto tipo un maglione una scelta
radicale di gaia tempi d'oro sarà
sarebbero essere bella ciao brucia
ospita io sono stato un anno particolare
giusto per farvi un esempio della sua
follia una volta per sostenere il fatto
che non gli facesse schifo lassù
si è creato in mano e ne ha mostrato lo
so che prima dice ciao
voglio capire pure a monte l'alterco tu
non sai chi sono io
io mi capo in mano chissà cosa ha
portato la pallamano da un invece il
rapporto alla cappella orario tornare in
atto quella vedere lo faceva nata in un
sacchetto attore siccome era invece lo
schifo polissi ignorato insomma un abete
si faccia pulita e sede della spa è la
cosa ancora più paura dice sei danno dai
e moriamo un giorno a tutti anche e
bello ed a questo è un minuto di
silenzio me tutti quanti quei sacchetti
quale madre e genere venuti nel mondo
dei bambini ma la madre a te b sono gli
e l'affidamento di tutti ea 25 anni
definisce ancora lettera almeno
all'intenso a metafore karimi e mi state
consolando in una maniera che li becca
video dio e invece lui sono tutte
ragazze e facciamo sera una domanda idea
moser a una ridotta praticamente un
rapporto sessuale lui mi chiamo vacca
leggermente mier offesa però continuato
tranquillamente a poi il giorno dopo ne
parlammo cli mi disse che era
ma lui intendeva senso del limite
galli la topolona mia qualche tempo dopo
sempre di rondo rapporto sesso ma che io
gli dissi sì un porco che lui si alzò vi
lascio al letto io rimasi basito al che
lo segue e lo trovai chiusa in bagno
seduto a piangere come un bambino perché
si offesa perché io non ti ho mai porco
sì ma il porco dal presupposto che
questa qui a roma da livelli termine
vacca a volte anche viene utilizzato
quale è un modo carino per dire
peripatetica tv patetica per ribaltarla
cioè un pochino
cioè sono quelle cose un progetto
insulto perché in realtà ti piace per
fare colore durante l'assalto fermo
anche pagare che porco capito cioè
quella roba un pochino
certo si e invece loro due ai vasi
decidersi si ferivano avviso è tutta
roba di colore non devi sentire in colpa
né di pensare che sia stato un giudizio
assolutamente no assolutamente giunta
del primario dovremo un po troppo chi
volevo raccontare di ogni ex un giorno
altro in camera sua e mi dice e poi mi
fa indossare i suoi vestiti
al che mi guarda mi dice ho sempre
sognato di approfitto anche per dirti
che ti seguo da quando 13 anni faccio
presente che gli scavi mi sa che le
mettesse cose da rugby hijacked vai in
famiglia voce e sappiamo che i tuoi
video da quando era un 11enne grazie a
raccontare di un ragazzo con cui mi sono
frequentano paio di volte
e vero motivo per cui è degno di nota
subito dopo che raggiungeva la grafici e
massimo del tedesco che ama ridere o no
leggero nordico di una famiglia bene
bravo meno male che esiste ma quello che
privata viene fatto viaggi quello prima
ancora si sta ancora definendo nelle
mani mettiamoli tutti dentro un
abbraccio un problema internet
così si chiama white e dico ma tu
mangimi 19
la differenza fra essere collegato al wi
fi il fatto che poi il papa ha quindi
frase dei comparti di la giusta strada
ho fatto la mia la cassa netto dove vi
chiedeva leccarmi il naso in particolar
modo perché io ci sono tantissimi non
sapevo nemmeno fossero erogene portare
il suo concetto di masturbazione da
questo non si riesca ma io nemmeno mi
sentirei una mano e piacevoli primo fu
invitato a questo matrimonio manicomio
adesso dopo anno dico vediamo meno nei
canali genere nel nostro interesse per
me mi porto in giardino per consumare
tre io ero dietro la ragazza ha
incominciato urlarmi di mm né di mm ed i
minimi fine tavole degli agent aula di
minuti ride come se non bastasse ha
incominciato ad attirare testate contro
il muro 18 risulta non si è tagliata la
droga giustificato agli archi o non ci
hanno di visto pensavano di aver si alza
domani
questa che non è così ma che fine hanno
fatto
xy non lo so io conosco una ragazza che
si è fatta a spaccare il naso contro un
termosifone come pugili per la gioia di
tutti i chirurghi estetici d'italia i
termosifoni anche i giovani non paga
è una leggenda chi è che c'è alle
orecchie gonfie dato ricevuto mamma
miglioramento visto le orecchie dei
lottatori di judo non lo so era troppo
presa a pensare a pugili l'onta dolori
niente mi ero già innamorata ed è tutto
finito
mandateci i vostri curriculum vitae gwis
con una bella
no io bado molto ha descritto
intellettuali quindi se siete redditi
oppure mandate forza zio toni questa
cazzata mandate curricolo il mio ex
a vent'anni si faceva allacciare le
scarpe dalla nonna da dalla zia che il
cucciolo vallora asti cuccioli di new
non sono capitati solo a me tu sei
avvelenando noi oggi ritengo però che ci
siano buone opportunità che il rugby che
non siano così si sta impazzendo
turistico così elevato io sud intanto a
chi oppure ti senti urlare in questo
inizio tra queste non torno più
non tira di più quella parola
voglio raccontare di quella volta in cui
io ero con il mio primo ragazzo e
cambiare prime armi certo punto quando
lui doveva scendere verso di me si
blocca riguarda che fa è bagnata e lì no
non è così
e no a me adesso asciutta ma che fu
proprio con la cazzuola e come se
l'avesse detto a me piace morbido perché
mi piacerebbe ma lui non aveva mai eh
beh penso proprio di no infatti lei ci
dice che era già alle primissime armi e
treze credo verrebbe fatto di pollo è
sceso odio non bellico anche un'altra
melillo io sono stato sei anni con
natalis fano ci sono lasciati l'anno
scorso con quei persiani avuto rapporti
lavorativi resisitito la storica fini
del dramma come fine della storia non
possiamo concludere con fine della
storia
dramma nel 2019 mai sentito parlare di
contraccettivi e lui questi sconosciuti
ma facevano altro beh ipotizzo di sì
tipo guardavano entra mondo ammette non
re del messaggio sembra abbastanza
chiaro trova di qualcuno e passa sei
anni ha eletto a rifiutare questa
stranissima donne primissimo ex da nulla
mi chiese di rinchiuderlo dentro divano
letto guardarti c'è io dovevo dare un
film seduto sopra divano letto con le
mie due amiche mentre lui stava sotto
perché
allora lo citava da morire non
attenzione lui che chiama le amiche le
migliori vengono a casa dei capi davvero
di la mia esperienza con gli ex
un'esperienza con una ex con la quale
sono stata house con gli anni che aveva
una malattia per il pulito pazzesca
bisognava ogni giorno a spirare casa
togliere le coperte da letto e aspirare
totalmente il letto e le coperte non
osavamo le scarpe lasciamo fuori sullo
zerbino a costo di farcele fregare e poi
soffriva di scatti e abbia pazzeschi per
cui aveva l'abitudine quando le capitava
sotto mano del cibo durante una lite di
farlo tipo detonare poi però impazziva
cominciano ad aspirare tutto e da lì in
poi sono andato a vivere da sola e
adesso sono nello zoom è felicissima
brava buona idea vice a chi non farebbe
mai una cosa così i rugbysti stata
censurata fino ad ora
luigi fa una cosa che io posso impazzire
non mi parlare male di luigi in
ginocchio dai semi stai guardando luigi
questo soltanto gliel'ho detto 20mila
volte e non è l'unica persona che lo fa
perché quando pulite per i suoi piatti e
cose così
lasciatela pezzetta bagnata dentro il
lavandino anno questa cosa me la faccio
nemmeno io penso che perché io ho uno
scolino per le pizzette che tu puoi
metterli a scolare questo è per niente
una persona particolare vuoi per temi
evidentemente
giovani coda mentre a guardare una bella
stagione di netflix uccide questa cosa a
te non è mai capitato che ad esempio di
punto in bianco sei camminando per la
strada e sentirlo stesso odore del 216
io quanti ricordi quante emozioni ma e
padri di otto ex per quanto ti di tiglio
anche delle volte del loro nome
appena sentito dolore ti ricordi subito
tutto cara o una soluzione un mio ex
aveva un profumo che mi faceva impazzire
la soluzione che il primo caso che
faccio agli uomini per i btp con cui
esco e questo è vero un esercito di
replicanti sono la morte nera che mi
trovo che si chiamano i capelli bianchi
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa puntata io ringrazio la linea
grazie a voi tutti voglio dare un
piccolo cadeau che il mio orecchio
sinistro
khartoum un poker online che sono
arrivati i delfini qui sono state
guardando fuori l'uscio di toglierlo
guardatelo coi sottotitoli che tra
parentesi almeno dico questa cosa che
non ho mai tempo di dire spesso mi
chiedete di rimettere i sottotitoli
sappiate che da un bel po di mesi i
sottotitoli ci sono sotto questi video
solamente che potete attivarli vi da la
possibilità o di vederlo senza
sottotitoli o se invece volete attivarli
mettere italiano ea quel punto andare
con dio e con dio spider man per dire ti
ringrazio david grazie è stato veramente
un piacere per me trascorrere il mio
tempo in tua compagnia come finta tua
cugina preferita
adesso torno alla mia miserrima
esistenza saputo tua zia ciao mamma
salutiamo l'associazione eroina christi
italia questo punto vi lasciamo i miei
migliori ai contatti di come sei un
ragazzo vi ringrazio per aver visto
questo video
lasciate un commento qui sotto se volete
commentare le storie avete sentito o
ancora meglio se volete condividere le
vostre iscrivetevi a questo canale
attive della campanellina per non
perdervi nessun video e noi come sempre
ci vediamo la prossima settimana sempre
alle 14 ciao
possiamo dare un messaggio nel turno di
pensarci tipo fumate rugbisti